welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul aka the guy who loves to
get hammered off white lightning and the
new Thor 11 Thunder trailer is upon us
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking it down because fate wills it
so there's a ton of Easter eggs hidden
details and also lots of callbacks to
the comic Storyline by Jason Aaron which
this movie seems to be based on now I
also want to go over elements of the
first trailer as that will help to flash
out part of this as well that opened
with three versions of Thor running
along on the same Planet because between
these as a sort of Montage to show Thor
running through the woods at different
ages the first could show them as a kid
and this is actually played by Chris
Hemsworth's son who he saw in behind the
scenes images next up was Thor and his
classic costume from the comics before
we got him in present day these three
versions of Thor are actually all notes
of the comic book Run As in that we
watch Thor's battle with Gore over three
different time periods this included his
youngest R from 893 A.D the present-day
Avenger one and a one from the far
distant future which had been battling
Gore's black Berserkers for over 900
years Through Time Travel go plucked
them all out of their homes and the
three teamed up together to take on the
villain I don't think that will happen
in the movie but it is important to bear
in mind now we know that after the
events of endgame the thought has been
in a state of relaxation and meditation
this is signified by the line his hands
were once used for battle
now they're about humble tools for Peace
So the guy is going on a journey of
self-discovery that will likely be
interrupted by Christian pale AKA Gaul
when the initial teaser dropped a lot of
people wondered what planet this was and
having re-read Aaron's graphic novel run
I believe that this is indigo the planet
was populated by blue aliens like what
we see in the teasers and it's also how
this story started off a girl on Indigo
ended up trying to thought to help them
and upon arriving there he discovered
that this was because the planet didn't
have any gods of its own you see in the
Marvel Universe every planet has its own
Gods that look after it and its people
however Indigo was the first planet
Thorin ever come across where there were
absolutely no Gods almost the entire
population had turned to atheists
believing Gods to just be fairy tales
and notion he found ridiculous upon
ascending into the heavens he found the
God's base in which they'd all been
butchered which no prices for guessing
who that is that all kind of set off
this almost murdered mystery section for
the first quarter of the book whereas in
the film it looks like we're gonna be
following Thor as he attempts to warn
the guards before Gore arrives the book
ends with Thor returning to Indigo to
pray with the girl from the beginning to
show him there are Gods which is how
this story could wrap up
[Music]
kids get to popcorner let me tell you
the story of the space Viking Thor
odenson now he opened with Korg talking
to the kids there and he can catch the
tree he was meditating under in the
background so potentially this might
even be him regarding the whole movie as
a story and it could be How It Ends now
the guardian seem like they're going to
go to Thor for help in fighting the
threat on the planet and after this
battle is over they'll fly into space
probably searching for Gamora who's
still out there at this point though
we'll be wearing his thunderstrike
costume which comes directly from the
comics however that Bloody that Bloody
tiger is also tied it in with a ravager
uniform which makes me think he got it
whilst traveling with the Guardians Thor
raises Stormbreaker and cast a lightning
spell and you might also notice that
Drax is in the bottom corner hiding see
Guy couldn't get his invisibility Powers
past me now Thor has double eyes again
which a lot of people call the CGI era
but personally I think that he's just
got a new fake one we learn in Avengers
Infinity war that Rockets smuggle it up
so it makes sense that he'd want to get
a different one instead of one that
smells like raccoon [ __ ] however both
the eyes being blue could somewhat show
balance in the character whereas in the
past movies they might have represented
Thor being fractured unhole or
incomplete not saying you guys with
heterochromia are incomplete a fractured
it's actually a mutation a very groovy
mutation he was a God
after saving planet Earth for the 500th
time Thor set off on a New Journey
well he got in shape
he went from dead board to God
and after all that he reclaimed his
title
as the one and only four
oh spook too soon you asked God also
looks thriving and you might also notice
that there's a golf course there King
Valkyrie has appeared alongside Meek
who's dressed up as a secretary and it
looks like they're holding meetings for
the greater world to get involved with
their dealings now at this point we see
the ship they'll be traveling through
the Stars on this is pulled by tooth and
Asher and tooth grinder who come
directly from the comics and legends
these two goats pulled the gods Chariot
through the sky and we can also see the
cocktails in dreams sign on it the polls
directly from Tom Cruise's film cocktail
hopefully this time he'll pop up as Iron
Man you dumb punk where the hell were
you everyone was saying you were gonna
be in it now we also see him on what I
believe is the car and he's goto with
him at this point really hoping that we
see Jeff Goldblum back as the Grand
Master and ghoul might even consider him
a God but let me know below exactly what
you think coupled with this are moments
of entraining whilst cognorates the
story we have him once more wearing an
Avengers cab with a classic logo but
over the top of this he's written
strongest Avenger which is another
nickname he kept trying to give himself
in Ragnarok now Jane Foster is the
Mighty Thor is going to be a big part of
the film we've already done a full video
breaking down what happens with her in
the comics but if you want a fast recap
then this part of the video is just for
you you some of a [ __ ] interestingly
she didn't appear in the God of Thunder
storyline but it looks like they're
squeezing her Origins into this much
like the MCU in the comic still had lost
Monier but he was deemed unworthy rather
than being destroyed by hella the hammer
called out to Jane who'd recently been
diagnosed with cancer and she ended up
picking it up whereas here it's clearly
been pieced back together my guess is
that because you have to be worthy to
lift it that the fragments of it
remained were hella left them either way
it's back baby and when Jane picked it
up she gained the powers of Thor however
there was a downside to it because it
basically made her invulnerable and the
cancer inside her also gained this
strength too so it ended up overpowering
her chemotherapy the more Jane used the
hammer the more the disease progressed
and after being told by her friends to
stop using it she she eventually stopped
however there was a big attack on Asgard
and she ended up picking the hammer up
once more she defeated the bad guy but
Acosta her life however Thor called out
to her soul at the gates of Valhalla and
managed to bring her back Jane vowed to
continue her chemotherapy and eventually
she got rid of her cancer now Jane ended
up becoming a valkyrie which I think is
probably how the movie is gonna end so
Thor will probably still be Thor for the
foreseeable future hey she also rides a
Pegasus in the teaser so I think that
this is further hitting at the role that
could be coming for her down the line
she ends up blasting molnir at one point
and the pieces all come apart like a
shotgun blast which is such a creative
thing to do with the cracked Hammer
they'll no doubt return to the handle
and potentially that's how it's held
together rather than being super glued
like we Chumps though yes we thought it
would be super glued where Chumps see a
chump the old ex-girlfriend
what's it finally three four years eight
years seven months and six days give or
take now once more we get a Living
Tribunal Easter egg and the character
recently popped up in Doctor Strange in
the Multiverse of Madness for a split
second I'm guessing that they're
building to his live-action appearance
at some point because he was also hinted
at in Loki too next we get Christian
Bale as Gore
the only ones who Gods care about
is themselves
is My Vow
oh God she won't die his introduction
seems absolutely terrifying and I love
how a lot of his scenes have this black
and white almost chrome-like feeling to
them with the toy leaks a lot of people
were let down worse than my dad was with
me but by the luck of it I think he
comes across as a terrifying villain and
I can't wait to see what he does in the
film Gore has a really cool backstory in
the comics that makes you completely
understand why he is the way he is and
that's what this movie seems to be
fleshing out we learn that he comes from
a harsh desert planet that had never
ending daylight and because of this the
natives of it had to avoid the Sun as
much as possible because of its
potential to kill them Gaul was brought
up by his mother believing that the gods
would take care of them but when she was
attacked by beasts and brutally killed
he started thinking differently his wife
also fell to her death whilst pregnant
with their child and Gore sick of having
to lick slime off rocks just to survive
ended up going on an angry rant to his
tribe in which he called the [ __ ]
Gods a bunch of stupid
foreign
now obviously the highly religious tribe
go mental because they worry that the
gods are going to wreak havoc on them
for their blasphemy so they Outcast him
he wanders through the desert and when
he's at that store he ends up seeing two
gods crashland in front of him one of
them being null this black goo from null
ended up infecting Gaul and it powered
him for Millennia also giving him access
to the necro sword a powerful weapon we
know that Bale will be carrying in the
film a Gore ended up murdering countless
guards throughout the cosmos because of
his first-hand experience with their
failings he viewed them as arrogant
benevolent beings that didn't care about
the people that worshiped them because
they were happy to let them live lives
of misery whilst they Reign on high his
whole mission was to build a weapon
known as the god bomb that would wipe
out all gods in the universe and far on
the future he used many gods as slaves
in order to construct it he managed to
capture the young Thor to help build
this and we also met his new wife and
child his wife ended up completely
worshiping him and realizing that he'd
somewhat become a God himself she called
him one banged by this girl killed her
and after his son discovered her body he
decided to help though the three thores
ended up battling with Gaul and the
Avengers one attached himself to the
bomb as it was in the process of
detonating all the gods in the universe
started to die and in their last moments
they prayed to Thor to save them which
powered him up enough to absorb the
weapon Gore was beheaded and the
Avengers version died though he did end
up coming back to life three days later
taiku watiti has said that he thinks
Gore is the best villain in the MCU and
I really can't wait to see what they do
with him the sources black Berserkers
which are basically beasts that Thor
fights throughout the comics now he was
tied somewhat to the Symbiote and the
source material but I don't think they
can really go that route because of Sony
but I I suppose no way home ended up
with one in the MCU I just don't know if
it'll strictly be that either way
watching The Darkness around this white
figure is such a cool image and it
really makes his introduction pop these
black and white scenes show up
throughout the trailer and it looks like
the final battle will be in these Bleak
worlds that look darker than 2020.
the other guy
also worth noting that this line pulls
directly from the comics and Gore's
fascination with Thor was purely because
he wasn't like a god that he'd ever
faced before and I'm a poet and I don't
know it but I'm not a rapper now we know
that Russell Crowe will be playing Zeus
I think he's gonna be used as a way to
show how powerful Gore is and he'll
likely be killed faster than the
Illuminati when they stop bragging about
what black belt's mouth does he resides
in Olympia a giant line of the Gods it
looks like it's based on an MC Asher
painting it is possible that this might
be combined with omnipotent city which
appeared in Jason Aaron's run the giant
flooding structure in the sky appears to
be similar to it and inside the location
was the Hall of the Lost which contained
Scrolls and books recounting all the
missing gods they'll use this to attempt
to track down all the gods who'd been
murdered by Gaul and this is where he
came across valigar the Behemoth the
image of his slaughtered corpse pulls
right from the comics and I love how
much these line up when you place the
images next to each other balogada
Behemoth was the champion of the
tournament of The Mortals for five
centuries a God who wrestled with black
holes for fun so Gore killing him shows
how powerful the villain is there's a
lot of shots of giant corpses across
both pieces that could show Gore's
Killing Spree we have the giant skeleton
whilst he wears the strongest Avenger
cap and the Kraken by the ship now in
the end he flicks too hard which is what
my wife said to me and we get to see the
guy that I stick up in the mirror really
nice trial out great way to end it and
uh yeah what a bloody bugger now I am
really excited for this film and if you
read the graphic novel then you'll know
we've got a lot to look forward to this
is a comic I recommend even if you're
not really into them as it's definitely
a standout Thor story this movie has a
lot resting on its shoulders but I trust
everyone to do their thing and really
bring out the big guns Christian Bale is
going to be a massive gap for Marvel and
though I know Multiverse of Madness was
divisive I think Marvel really did a lot
with Wonder in terms of making her an
unforgettable villain I really want to
see the same thing for Gore and hope
this movie delivers whilst also doing
Justice to the Jane Foster Rock anyway
that's my thoughts on the trailer and
obviously I'd love to hear yours below
if you want something else to watch
we've got a video linked on screen right
now so you better head over there
otherwise I'm I'm really gonna be angry
so hungry all the time I'm so angry you
don't hear over there thanks for the
click thanks for watching the ads thanks
for the money yes son of a [ __ ] I'll
see you next time peace